you're an actor you do all the training
you're in phenomenal shape your thinking
you great I'm gonna go in to pretend to
be a boxer but then they cost you up
with real boxers yes it's not cruel it's
it makes it believable we need real
fighters in there to really sell it you
know honestly and you know Florian's
great he's a he was a pro fighter in
Romania and sly found them online he was
had these crazy workout montages where
he was like you know bicep curling
pitbulls and doing all types of crazy
workouts and he's like 65 240 pounds
he's a massive massive human being and
and it worked because you know you know
Dolph was way taller than sly and that
kind of David and Goliath kind of feel
we wanted to kind of reenact that and
and reimagine that one so if it made it
make sense in the first movie that was
also a real box yeah Tony yeah yeah and
there's that famous clip it obviously
didn't make it to the film so explain
what happened so it was Sylvester
Stallone's Faulk yeah I mean sly enjoys
putting me through punishment he really
does he's so mischievous but um you know
in the rocky the rocky films it's like
it's like a badge of honor to take a
real punch and when you do slo-mo shots
you can't fake it you know cuz if you
you know if you did a slo-mo shot and it
was a Miss you would see the space and
it just wouldn't it wouldn't connect so
you have to take a real punch and sly
was like you know he was sitting in the
corner he was pacing and he was kind of
looking like not it's not gonna work
it's not gonna work and he finally gets
up and says Mikey listen you got to take
a real punch and I'm like ok did you do
it he said yeah I did I did a bunch of
times ok if you did it I'll do it and
and we ended up setting up the cameras
and we took her okay so this is this is
Michael B Jordan taking a real player in
in the first film here we go
[Applause]
i watch see know the crazy thing was
[Laughter]
this shot was I got hit and I went down
and then the camera panned in it was on
Steadicam and it panned in and it was
you know it was in slow motion and the
first time we did it Tony's glove was in
the way so we didn't see it right so us
they didn't see it at all so we had to
do it again so he did it the second time
and I got hit and everybody I could feel
the energy of the crowd of everybody
that was in the studio and I was like
all right it must have really looked
good because everybody's quiet I could
literally hear hear a pin drop in there
and I was just hoping the producers
didn't run in and just say cut because
they thought I was really hurt because I
was I was definitely seeing stars it was
definitely not I was not all there
smelling the canvas and everything I'll
never forget it it smelled like pine saw
it was there was it it was insane but um
yeah I took a real punch it felt like I
was in a car accident for like four days
Tony said he only went 40 percent it
felt like 85 it was
was tough it was tough cuz if you even
experience being knocked out haven't you
yes yeah I have but not in a fight no I
played ice hockey and I was a goalie and
I got here with a puck and was knocked
out we were up in Canada playing a team
up there and when you when you go when
you travel you tend to stay at someone
else's house like that you know the
other goalies family I say yeah their
family so they their family ran out onto
the ice to see if I was okay said Steve
Steve what's my name and I had no idea
what his name I said I don't know
they're like oh my god
[Music]
you